every year adam sandler will send in his
brackets now what happens is Sandman is
too busy too important and he has a crew
that helps him with his brackets and he
has his best friend Locke who was you
know from Philadelphia and obviously
pulling for Villanova so they had
Villanova going winning the national
title so they sent in two brackets and
all of a sudden I look and Sandler and
is in his buddy lock are 12 in the
celebrity bracket challenge and here's
Adam Sandler calling in congratulations
this is better than winning an Academy
Award I have already won several kaveri
water I didn't even feel a thing with us
yes I felt nothing this felt this felt
right and let me create Danny Boy this
is this I did this one on my own I
didn't have anyone would be and la
current me and locker did it in my
little crappy trailer and and I'm happy
I did okay and I'm very happy for Locker
my god the filling all the thing was
huge you don't have a crappy little
trailer by the way I've been in your
trailer it's it's it's nicer than what
you have a studio let's race over the
studio apartment in New York no that's
when it's my movie I'm doing like a
little old man doing like what look real
fan movies we I pretend I care about the
art and all that stuff so I'm stuck in a
little trailer without brackets man it
was rough wait wait rock is this the
movie with Dustin Hoffman yeah man no
tell him I'm pretending how much you're
getting for this Harry like 15 grand no
I brought my kids here and my wife in
this spending a lot of money I got
nothing the tablet was a terrible
physical your bracket strategy you know
since you filled out your bracket maybe
you could help the audience here just so
next year there they'll have Adam
Sandler's bracket strategy well here was
my thought throughout the whole day the
only mistake I made that locker help me
correct because I did do it all my own
was
I had Yale going the whole way and he
said no that's not gonna happen but the
rest i just said you know I've watched a
little little ball this year so I kind
of knew sigh at some thought but and
then there was some just guessing and
stuff yes it and and but and then there
was on occasion whatís I wanted to work
for some reason I don't even know why
but uh I because i don't have one
college soon my love who who's your team
I didn't have why went to dayton but I
had them beating see returns and then
losing the next game I mean you went to
NYU I was yeah the vilest didn't make it
this year million going to and fearless
yeah no but I yeah I I wanted of course
I wanted to refuse to go deep and I was
as happy they played so well and then
the last night's game I was incredible
one of the best games I've ever seen in
my life if you could have gone to
another school instead of nyu would you
have gone to a sports cool yeah you know
what yeah you know but because I i went
to a sports cool i won't be cool also
there won't be better at NYU I was
almost known as an athletic yes that was
the beauty of nyu like wow that guy can
bomb anything dribble could you did you
try out for the nyu basketball team no
oh you can happen I know nothing about
my life I just I was sitting the bench
in high in high school I you I knew I
was going nowhere with my sports did I
ever tell you my father I told him I was
gonna go pearl in baseball and I was
like laying in bed we were talking as I
guess it'll grow in baseball no you look
good no you're not come on out you guys
you did not well that's that's a
heartwarming story hey man that daddy
had to lay down the law my life it don't
have you dumb dreams you too slow are
you gonna brag to anybody on the movie
set today are you gonna say something to
Dustin Hoffman today well that I shake
him up with every move I make oh yeah I
will tell that the boy that it does a
multi number two dusty boy I know a
number two
Lockley go number one with no streets in
the heart he liked to do it over he said
he'd likely that's all the routes for
spilling over the Eagles the flyers in
the end the Sixers he and in the
Phillies he has he's having a rough time
everywhere else going over is going to
make them happy for about three years so
you got this movie and then you got
another movie coming out to do over with
David Spade yeah you know that song at
the end of may with you man and you're
fantastic yes Mei Mei some 21st or
something you can let me into the skull
hello yeah you can bring it up by you
can bring it up thank you see you soon
one second you got it he's outside my
door dinner apparently my wife bought
something yeah tell you what is it okay
hey buddy that's for me hey hang on hang
on let me get you something okay it's a
garment bag everybody and it says it
says a lot of money in the front 16
grand for a shirt no I'm just making how
much are you tearing the god brother how
much you tip in the gun I got it I'm
looking for 20 i'm looking for a 20 well
would you do honey would you do a 20 if
if you weren't on the phone with me i no
no i wouldn't you devil hey hang on
buddy I like oh yeah come please he's
getting his daughter to go get him money
no that's why he looked so confused
right now cuz he's like he's tipping all
this cheating rest yeah start Sonny just
woke up anything you want to probe and
Paul kick the man who plays your daddy
in the movie oh don't say hi and she got
shot on me okay we went to the museum of
that this is what happened yesterday we
were going to a yankee game we got
rained out and we went to the museum of
natural history somehow I lost big on
that have you thrown out the first pitch
at a Yankee game yes me and Chris Rock
did it together oh that's right okay it
was it was fun yeah it was great but uh
yeah he asked for the game the game got
rained out yesterday plant 8 a 1 i'm
making affecting that said to get rained
out yesterday do you know buddy I'll get
some of my people I'll get some of my
best people call you guys
I love you I love you I Michigan I'm
sorry I sound insane I'm whispering
because the kids were sleeping now ones
up and and we get we miss you I love you
is your wife they're my wife went to
whole foods to get me she said I gotta
start drinking this stuff that'll make
me feel better about my life to some
proactive probiotics what the comment
probiotic crap that I've been drinking
all of a sudden it sounds like it sounds
like no I don't know no I don't need to
i just drink beer hang on hang on
Sonny's gonna say one thing about it go
ahead it's not common country it's not
crap it's good for it not cook yeah that
was her quote of the day now yeah isn't
that cute now I gotta really drink it by
the way I was telling him he's gonna
when we were in Hawaii and we went out
drinking with Dave Matthews yes eight
again the end was that when we were in
Hawaii we went out drinking with the
Dave Matthews you had me across the
table from him and and my first beer i
spelled I spilled it on Dave Matthews
but I made I made up for it the rest of
the night but my introduction to Dave
Matthews I spilled my beer all over you
know you're just another nervous man go
I can't believe I'm sitting next to the
david dave' man no I know it uh we knew
what we discussed the other day what
that morning jog you took on grown ups 2
when you got up after a night of fun and
you said you said something I locker and
said you said okay now it sounded I
forget like make make the neighborhood
happy or something some pretty dress oh
that's why for a morning jog we went
deep that night right we were watching
um and NBA funny water that we're
watching basketball yeah all right yeah
I have you had to entertain the
neighborhood is what i did i put on
those short shorts and I took a job at
looks more than i meant 'take oh god
your shorty shorts or the bet you did a
day to you went jogging in the speed
over there that was the best part of the
whole trip and you know who you don't ya
and you know who greeted me when I got
back to your house your wife Garrett
your wife was there going huh hi it was
awkward it's awkward moment she say hi
hi hey and there anything why can you
fill yours up like this yeah I know
alright so I'll see you in may maybe at
the premiere yeah then i gotta gonna do
something's coming up soon and we're
gonna drag you into it again and i love
you hi buddy I'll talk to you soon
congrats on your bracket so long i said
congrats ooh most important thanks for
being cool about my brother and hello to
my brother my brother had villanova 1
and 2 by the way and we watched whenever
I'd gone visit Scott in Boston we were
watching that the games are like the
only thing that made him happy the mg
double-a stuff and he's any pic no but
so there you go good good I'm glad he's
doing better all right thank you buddy
okay legs Adam Sandler say hello to
Scott his brother the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience